en el vídeo pasado encontramos el
volumen entre esta superficie que es xy
cuadrada y el plano x y cuando x va de 0
a 2 y lleva de 0 a 1 la forma en la que
lo hicimos fue integrar primero con
respecto a x es decir lo que dijimos fue
vamos a dejar una fija para encontrar el
área debajo de la curva moviendo x esto
no sea un área que dependía de cada i y
luego integramos estas áreas con
respecto a iu pero a lo mejor se puede
hacer al revés es decir fijando un valor
de x y comenzando por integrar con
respecto al vale pues hagamos esto
esperemos que esta otra forma de hacerlo
nos dé la misma respuesta ok entonces
déjame borrar varias de las cosas que
tenemos aquí recuerda que la respuesta
que nos dio fue dos tercios y si este
experimento no sale bien entonces
tendríamos dos formas de encontrar la
respuesta lo cual está padre va déjame
redibujar la gráfica para que podamos
volver a explicar la intuición este de
aquí es el eje de las x
este de acá es el eje de las yes este es
el eje de las setas entonces déjame
marcarlos aquí le voy a poner x aquí le
voy a poner y acá le voy a poner z ahora
lo que voy a hacer es dibujar el
rectángulo en el cual estamos integrando
a ver déjame ver queda más o menos algo
así
y luego queda una marca paralela al eje
x por acá
aquí está x igual a 1 aquí esta x
igualados y por aquí está igual a 1
ahora sí voy a intentar lo más que pueda
hacer un dibujo bonito entonces queda
algo más o menos así déjame ponerlo con
otro color a ver la gráfica viene más o
menos así sube
sube más o menos así y luego baja recto
una cosa de este estilo
ahora el volumen que nos importa es este
de aquí este que le estoy dando un poco
de perspectiva aquí está la parte
superior de la superficie y lo que nos
importa es el volumen debajo de la
superficie es decir bueno voy a marcar
por aquí un poquito un poco más oscuro
para que se vea como cómo se va
levantando la hoja
queremos poner un poco de sombras
listo creo que con esto ya tiene un poco
más de volumen
entonces vamos a ver pues si mira es más
o menos como estarle dando la vuelta a
la página de un libro sale entonces
vamos a intentar encontrar el volumen la
vez pasada lo que hicimos fue fijar un
ahí pero ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
empezar fijando una equis es decir vamos
a dejar una equis fija vamos a tomar un
valor de x el que sea digamos a ver lo
voy a marcar con este color que es verde
y lo voy a marcar más o menos a la mitad
digamos por aquí entonces ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es un corte paralelo al
plano y ez va entonces ahí lo voy a
subir tantito para que veamos cómo va el
corte si dejamos una equis constante por
ejemplo x igual a 1 nos queda z igual a
ye cuadrada entonces vamos a poder
encontrar el área debajo de una curva
cuando hacemos el corte queda más o
menos algo así entonces la curva de la
cual es de la cual estoy hablando es
esta
algo así
déjame sombrear la y lo que nos gustaría
hacer es encontrar el área debajo de
esta curva como le vamos a hacer para
encontrar esto pues lo que vamos a hacer
es ver esto como una función zeta igual
a xy cuadrada pero recuerda que x ya
está fija es decir es una función de dos
variables pero por el momento x está
fija nuestra base de los rectángulos va
a ser de jeff porque ahora el pequeño
cambio va a ser en que tenemos que
multiplicar por la altura de este
rectángulo que es igual a xy cuadrada y
entonces que nos quedan tenemos xy
cuadrada que es la altura x belle que es
la base y lo que queremos hacer es
integrar todos todos todos estos
rectángulos para hacer esto tomamos la
integral de 0 a 1 y recordemos que
estamos moviendo la aie
entonces bueno ya teniendo el área de
esta de esta curva de aquí podríamos
sumar todas estas áreas y al final
dándole un poco de profundidad aquí lo
voy a marcar algo así
déjame darle un poco luego a poner con
otro color para que se vea la
profundidad a veces me siento como ese
ese chico que dibuja en la televisión
pero fíjate entonces ahora tenemos el
volumen de esta área es decir como que
la área la multiplicamos por de xy se
volvió un volumen y si integramos todos
estos volúmenes que son muy muy muy muy
delgados en todos los valores de x vamos
a obtener el volumen debajo de la
superficie es decir hay que integrar
desde x igual a cero hasta x igual a 2
muy bien entonces vamos a pensarlo
tantito esta área que es verde que está
aquí en verde debería de ser una función
de x es decir si dejamos una x constante
y movemos la y nos debería quedar una
función de x aquí en esto que está de
color rosa entonces después eso lo vamos
a poder integrar con respecto a x y ya
encontrar el volumen vamos a ver si es
cierto vamos a dejar x constante y cuál
es la anti derivada de ya cuadrada pues
es llega al cubo entre 3
aquí nos queda y al cubo entre 3
multiplicada por equis
acuérdate que x es una constante
entonces tenemos que evaluarlo de 0 a 1
y luego tenemos que integrar de 0 a 2 b
x
entonces vamos a hacer esta integral de
aquí adentro a ver si ponemos ya igual a
1 nos queda 1 al jugo que es un tercio x
x que es una constante y luego hay que
restar menos 0 al cubo que cuando todo
eso de ahí nos va a dar 0 entonces esta
expresión de aquí que está en color pues
morado es x tercios
páez x x 1 entre 3 - 0 y ahora va la
integral de afuera la integral de afuera
va de 0 a 2 de x y entonces fíjate ya
que fijamos una x el área de esta
superficie verde está dada por x tercios
va eso fue justamente lo que nos dijo la
primera integral que hicimos esta que
estoy marcando aquí es x tercios para x
igual a 1 esto nos da un tercio pero
conforme movamos la x
vamos a ir obteniendo otras áreas
entonces ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es integrar con respecto a x para sumar
todas estas áreas va entonces vamos a
integrar con respecto a x x tercios eso
pues es una integral súper fácil de las
que ya conocemos así ésta
tranquilidad normal y cuál es su ante
derivada pues es x cuadrada entre 2 pero
aparte por ahí hay un tercio entonces
nos queda x cuadrada entre 2 x 3 que es
y esto de aquí tenemos que evaluarlo con
límite superior 2 e inferior 0 2 al
cuadrado entre 6 nos queda 4 sextos
menos 0
y esto de aquí simplemente es cuatro
sextos cuántos cuatro efectos pues
simplificando nos quedan dos tercios
entonces el volumen es dos tercios y
está súper bien si nos acordamos del
vídeo pasado esta es la misma respuesta
que obtuvimos dejando primero fijo y
después integrando con bueno con
respecto a y en resumen pudimos voltear
el orden de integración y obtuvimos la
misma respuesta uff qué bueno todo va de
maravilla mira todavía acabamos con un
poco de tiempo de sobra déjame traer
otra vez la superficie para divertirnos
rotando la un poco
wow qué diversión ahí está va entonces
el volumen que encontramos fue este de
aquí que está entre la superficie y el
plano xy
al final de cuentas dio igual en qué
orden integramos por el momento es todo
lo que te tengo que contar nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo